please welcome pro skater and
entrepreneur Tony Hawk welcome thank you
it's incredible to watch these clips I
am thinking do you have that do you have
a balance that is better than my balance
even when you're off the board I I don't
know I guess we could test it find out
but I think I didn't I don't think I was
naturally gifted when I was young
especially skating when I first started
skating I it was it was intimidating it
was difficult and I just kept at it I
mean that was my only secret was just
perseverance
so you started from from zero absolutely
yeah
yeah I was I was not a good skater at
the beginning I I just want to show a
clip I found a clip on the Internet
and it's a clip where you you can
explain what you're doing here it's
quite recently ah
that is a 900 spin so that is two and a
half rotations in the air something that
I first did in 1999 at the X Games best
trick event at the time it was the most
spins anyone had ever done and that was
just about 2 years ago where I revisited
that trick again into my older age and
it was not any easier
is it possible to explain what's going
through your head when when you're up
there and tarney uh fine landing find
the landing final landing it's really a
matter of if you take off and you you
sort of know everything had worked up to
that point then it's more just waiting
until you realize you've done the full
spin the complete spin and then trying
to find the spot you're gonna land
because that moment is a fraction of a
second and a lot of times you will spot
it too early or think you you spun it
enough and you haven't and there's
plenty of examples in that same clip
where I came out on my back or I came
around and I was
sliding my wheels just weren't quite
turned enough and and all those little
things it just it just takes multiple
attempts that's it
as I understand it you are you are the
privilege is when you invent the trick
right you get to name it
right yeah yeah so if you were to
describe something that you did which
was quite advanced for Diane here okay
in skate skating language haha sound Wow
so I'd say at one time I did a 360
barrel to fakie and then I came up and
did a fakie frontside caballerial
Madonna and the through reread at the
bottom I didn't really do that but
that's possible yeah reminds me of the
the vintners the the people that name
their wines you know they describe the
wines so creative but but it's a you're
a skater mom right yeah my youngest is
31 and my oldest is 36 and they're both
surfers now but yeah
they did you know the surfers dad to
have the skateboard shoes I took him to
the park where I live you know they were
instrumental in getting a skateboard
park cool created which you know the
city was totally against you know
because who's gonna insure this thing
really the reason I me think the reason
I became a skateboarder is because my
older brother was a surfer and he
started skating in the late 70s and and
I inherited one of his old boards and
that's how I started where is that board
now at the Smithsonian
[Applause]
till tell me about injuries because III
I suspect that you must have hurt the
most most parts of your body is there
somewhere you never hurt well I've never
broken my leg I never thought I
fractured my pelvis basically broke it
that was the hardest thing to recover
from I broke my elbow my thumb I
fractured my skull I've had countless
stitches in my shins oh yeah all for the
sake of progression and still here when
you hurt yourself as an athlete even
when you heal the body will remember and
it can make you more careful and it can
actually be a disadvantage even after
your your right I found that true when
my putt when I hurt my pelvis
there was about a year that I had to
readjust my skating because my body was
subconsciously doing that and basically
because I broke it on this side I was
leaning further back than usual and I
found myself falling backwards way more
often than usual in fact a couple times
I actually broke my skateboard because I
was so far in the back foot that I broke
the tail off my skateboard and that's
when I realized that something's off
here and I have to try to overcompensate
because of that and it took a long time
but but I think that's true
I'm sitting here thinking because the
the two of you started out very
different in life when you were 14 you
were a professional skater young how did
the teachers respond to that escaping
with such small community and and being
pro just meant that you you entered if
you entered a competition on the entry
form you check the pro box instead of
the amateur box that was it there was no
contract there was no money there's no
celebration so and there was no future
so my teachers didn't take it that
seriously so they weren't very they
weren't giving me much leeway in terms
of oh will you go ahead and make up your
work later it was like what the hell are
you doing
you know I you know being a pro skater
was the equivalent of being a
professional yo-yo player and it wasn't
until I was 17 when I started actually
making money that that it became more of
an issue because because that they were
still they were saying like you have to
figure out what you do with your life
you have to figure out your career and I
was like I think I have a career yeah
making money and I own a house and I'm
still in high school that seems like a
career to me you know and they they were
saying well most of it was just like
it's not gonna last
to be fair it didn't last it didn't last
much longer I had a good run yeah but
definitely in from the ages of say 17 to
21 yeah
the skating fell out of fashion and then
after that it started falling out yeah
it was definitely um less and less
popular each year until around 1992 when
it was just the bottom fell out how was
that for you personally how was that for
you it must have changed your life quite
dramatically yeah I was uh I was 24 with
a child on the way to mortgages and
saying I don't know what I'm gonna do I
don't skateboard doesn't seem like it's
lasting and I took a chance and started
my own skateboard company at the time
which seemed like the most ridiculous
idea but but it just showed how devoted
I was to the sport like I love
skateboarding so much that I was willing
to risk everything just to be in control
of a skate brand because I thought my
career as a skater was over you know
like in those days if you're in your 20s
that's that was that the top end of the
age limit of what people thought you
could be relevant and so I said okay I'm
gonna start a company and start my own
team and be able to guide them because
with your my experience for you being a
businessman is is now a big part of your
life yeah it was never the intention but
definitely became that if you had to
choose between being rich or being
famous what would you choose
oh rich over here also it's interesting
you say that because when I got into
skateboarding
nobody was rich or famous right so that
was never the goal of why you started
doing it or why you wanted to get good
at it and with other sports that was
always the underlying factor was that if
you're if you're a pro basketball player
you you're rich and famous we were just
saying we don't care about mainstream we
don't care if you accept us we're doing
our thing we have our own style we have
our own music we have our own our own
culture I I saw some pictures of your
house and it looks like it's like a
playground
yeah well has a skatepark I think that's
what you're getting at yeah yeah yeah my
wife and I we have many children we have
six kids total yeah
and so it's really as selfish as it is
to have a skate park it's for them they
all skate and they always have they
skate the backyard way more than I do
are they good yeah they're all pretty
good yeah one my oldest son is a pro
skater the rest of them are are very
accomplished in skating but they're not
making a career out of it yeah your
oldest son can he do things that you
can't do in him absolutely
yeah he can do stuff that I could never
have done because skating has evolved so
intensely over the last 10 20 years and
the things that they're doing now and
the things that he's doing now are
things that we only imagine doing in
video games 20 years ago what do you
think is the biggest misconception that
people have about skating that it's for
outcasts that it's for kids with no
motivation but still today you have like
businessmen on electrical skateboards on
the way to true yeah I think it's that
serious spec that thorn dear do you find
it silly no I hate whatever gets you on
a skateboard it's cool with me
but but I think that the misconception
is that skaters are lazy and that you
know they party and they wake up blade
and they're breaking into schoolyards
and some of those elements exist in
different stages but I think that if you
really look at the people who are
accomplished on skateboards it takes a
sense of discipline and perseverance and
dedication that is unlike many many
sports and if you want to be good at it
you have got to devote yourself to it
the thing is that next year the
skateboard will be a part of the
Olympics and which is which you have
rooted for is there also an ambivalence
towards that is it also coming out
there's always there's always going to
be either naysayers and there's always
going to be a backlash anything in
skateboarding people coveted so much and
they don't want it to be mainstream they
don't you know but but that was the same
through the years of corporate
sponsorships where I got a lot of flack
for that it was like what why do you
have a sponsorship with Bagel Bites like
that doesn't make sense and then as as
as it evolves I was sort of the first to
get that heat as it evolved then
suddenly it's Nike and it's it's Red
Bull and it's all these big companies
sponsoring skaters for the last 10 years
and so now with the Olympics then it's
the next level of well what are they
doing there you know if they're
bastardizing skateboarding they're
selling it out it's like now we're gonna
do the same you're not you're not
literally being reinventing the wheel
we're the same competition formats gonna
happen
it'll be on a bigger stage bigger venue
a bigger audience and if nothing else
it'll help grow it internationally Tony
it's wonderful to have you on the show
we're gonna have another guest on thank
you very much Tony okay hope you enjoyed
the clip for more interesting
conversations please hit subscribe
you